it was once the world's largest iceberg
a68 weighed billions of tons covered an
area of nearly 6 000 square kilometers
and was about 230 meters thick
today the mega bird has virtually
vanished
melted into smaller pieces not worthy
of being tracked by scientists
a 68 was carved from an ice shelf on the
edge of the antarctic peninsula
once it broke off in 2017 it hardly
moved for a year
before drifting north with increasing
speed
the mammoth block of ice even threatened
to strike land
it veered dangerously close to south
georgia
impact which could have been devastating
to the island's fragile ecosystem
iceberg carving and breaking away from
ice sheets and ice shelves actually
happens naturally so it's not
necessarily in and of itself
a worrying thing what is slightly
concerning is that if
more icebergs are breaking away and they
disintegrate
and collapse that could lead to an
acceleration of
the glaciers that feed into them and
that would contribute
to sea level rise even in the midst of a
global pandemic
climate change is very much still on the
political agenda
china and the united states the world's
largest carbon polluters
put diplomatic tensions aside and
pledged a joint commitment to tackling
the issue
countries are simply not getting the job
done
even if we did everything that we set
out to do in the paris agreement
the earth's temperature is going to
increase a very significant amount
perhaps as much as 3.7 degrees or more
and the reason and the reason for the
real urgency now is that
because we're not getting done what we
said we do in paris it's actually
heading towards four degrees or more
that's beyond catastrophic
it simply will not be possible to
stabilize climate change
unless superpower super polluters pull
much harder
cooperation between these countries is
critical
without it these landscapes of natural
glacial beauty
will quickly deteriorate in saman rashid
sky news